-Dwayne Johnson,
welcome back to the show.
-Good to see you guys.
Whoo!
Good-looking crowd.
-Come on, buddy.
-Oww!
Man, I've gotta tell you.
-Whoo!
-So -- yes!
Thank you.
The tequila is flowing tonight
in New York City, baby.
-It definitely is.
-I gotta tell you,
and I gotta tell you,
it's been years.
It is so good to be back.
-Yeah, come on, bud.
Live audience, too.
-Live audience, live audience.
-I want -- there's so much
I want to ask you,
but I want to get into
the girls first.
We have girls of similar ages.
-We do.
-How old are yours now?
-We're girl dads.
-Yeah, we're girl dads.
-Whoo!
-Whoo for the girl dads, yes.
-Yes.
-I have 21, I have 6, and 4.
-Yeah.
And the 6 and 4 --
-6 and 4.
-They're doing very clever,
funny things to you
that I think are great.
You might not love them
as much as I do.
-[ Laughs ]
It is terrifying to me.
But we play this --
we play their favorite game.
It's called
"Daddy, Close Your Eyes."
[ Laughter ]
And what comes after that
is whatever comes.
-You never know.
"Daddy, Close Your Eyes,"
and they just drew a unibrow,
a mustache, and a goatee.
And look at this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. They're creative.
That mustache.
-That is
"Daddy, Close Your Eyes."
I had to lay in bed, by the way,
for 25 minutes to do that.
-And then, also,
this is one of my favorites.
This is how your daughter
woke you up.
-Oh, this is how she woke me up
the other day,
as a matter of fact.
Again, come running in,
7:00 a.m.,
"Daddy, close your eyes."
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
Watch the video.
-Close your eyes!
-Okay, okay.
All right.
I trust you.
3, 2, 1.
Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-They just laugh, right?
They just laugh.
-They just laugh and laugh, and
you've just got to laugh it off.
-Yeah, it's the best thing
in the world.
-But you know what?
When they're this age,
and you guys know out there,
like, I'm in it.
'Cause, you know, you've only
got a finite amount of time,
so I'm girl dad all the way.
-Whatever they want.
-"Daddy, close your eyes,"
I'm doing it.
-I'll do it.
I'm gonna end up doing it, too.
We had Jay Pharoah on the show
a couple weeks ago.
And he's a good friend
of the show.
Unbelievable impressionist.
And he does
an impression of you.
And I don't know
if you've ever seen --
-I love Jay.
He's amazing.
-Yeah.
-He does impressions.
-Check out his impression
of you, of Dwayne Johnson.
-How about The Rock?
-You know what, jabroni,
The Rock says this --
If you're gonna read my name,
call me Dwayne Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not bad.
-He's good. He's good, man.
-He's good, right?
-He's good.
-We have a lot of people
that come on the show
do impressions of you.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
You might know this guy.
Look at this guy.
-And then he's like,
"Uw-wuh-wuh-wuh-wuh."
That's how he talk.
"Uw-wuh-wuh-wuh-wuh.
Uw-wuh-wuh-wuh-wuh."
-All right, this is --
-"Uw-wuh-wuh-wuh-wuh."
-All right.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Is that right?
-Wow!
-He came on here and did that?
-He came out here and did that.
I couldn't believe it.
-I just, "Uw-wuh-wuh-wuh."
-That's pretty good.
-It's not bad, actually.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, dude, but you were
laughing at that.
-No!
No, no, no, no, no!
-I just saw that!
-I would never do that!
[ Laughter ]
I was like, I thought
that was horrible.
I go, "We're never gonna
air that twice."
[ Laughter ]
And run it when Dwayne's here.
Never.
-Thank you very much,
by the way.
-Do you have any thoughts
about that or any --
-I mean, look, you know,
I try to do
a Kevin Hart impersonation,
and he just comes out --
"Hey, yeah,
this is what I'm gonna do!
I got a tequlia,
I got a this, I got a that.
And I got a this.
What you do?
Hey, Jimmy, yeah, you.
And then, hey, that's all right.
That's how I talk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shut up.
-Stop that.
We have to talk about
"Black Adam."
Gosh, I feel like we've been
talking about this
for a long time.
-For a long time, man.
For years and years and years.
-You were focused on this,
and you said,
"This is the one I want to do.
I'm a DC fan.
I'm gonna -- This is the one
I'm gonna make into a --
-I have been a DC boy
growing up.
And DC -- and I'm still a boy
'cause I'll never grow up.
-Yeah, exactly.
Right, yeah.
-So, "Black Adam" was important.
And this has been
a passion project of mine.
So, just yesterday,
I got sent the original article
announcing me playing
Black Adam 15 years ago.
-Is that right?
-I pushed and fought
so hard for this movie
to be made.
And I'll give you the context
behind that is, 15 years ago,
you and I both were in different
positions in our careers.
-Completely.
-So, when we announced
that I was gonna play
Black Adam, it was just harder
for the studio partners to look
past the Justice League.
They saw Superman and Batman
and Wonder Woman
and Aquaman and Flash.
And I love --
I love the Justice League,
and I love Superman.
But I always felt that,
you know, if you look past that,
there's some really cool
characters in the DC Bible,
for example, like Black Adam
has all the powers of Superman.
But Superman won't kill
because he has a code of honor
and a code of ethics,
which we appreciate and love.
But Black Adam will kill you.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that's it.
-That's as simple as that.
Black Adam will kill you.
-Boom.
-But you were telling me, when
they were making the super suit
for you, for Black Adam...
-Yes, yes.
I mean, you -- you are The Rock.
You are Dwayne Johnson.
You are just in awesome shape.
And you go, "Yeah, all right."
And you got the suit,
and the first one
had, like, pads in it, right?
-Dude, with the muscle --
with the superhero costumes,
all throughout the super--
like, Marvel and DC,
they all have these
muscle paddings in them.
-Of course.
-Which is just what you do.
So, you can imagine
that muscle suit,
Black Adam muscle suit,
with muscle padding
on top of my body.
It looked like you and I
were going back to "SNL"
to do a sketch.
[ Laughter ]
It was, like, ridiculous.
So, I asked them
to remove the muscle padding.
And I really wanted
to work hard.
I wanted to get in
the best shape of my career
for this because I felt like
Black Adam just commanded
that kind of performance.
-What does it take
to get into that --
'Cause you're already
in good shape.
What you're eating,
how you're working out.
-It was the diet.
It was the training.
It was the volume
of the training.
And then, also,
the challenge is,
when you get to a certain point
and you peak,
the challenge was I just had to
maintain it for four months,
which was challenging.
But here's the thing, I got
one shot with "Black Adam."
It's the most important movie
of my career,
and I pushed all chips in.
I worked my ass off,
and that's what we're gonna do.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, the suit is basically
just like a skin-tight --
-Now it's a very thin material
that is on my body.
-This is how Dwayne Johnson
looks as Black Adam.
Look at this.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude.
I mean, dude,
this is the greatest.
I think this is gonna
change the game.
We saw a screening
with a bunch of people,
and it was unbelievable.
Getting cheers
all the way throughout.
There's Easter eggs.
-There's Easter eggs.
-There's Easter eggs
all throughout the whole movie.
-And we also wanted to build out
the DC Universe.
I've been a fan of DC --
Again, as a little boy,
I was a fan.
I love Superman.
He was my favorite growing up.
But I didn't know until I saw
my first Black Adam comic,
when I saw the Black Adam comic,
he was intense,
he looked badass.
He had brown skin.
And I thought, "Wait a second.
That's me.
I want to be that guy."
-Yeah.
-And so, the idea was
to build out the DC Universe.
So, in "Black Adam," we
introduce five new superheroes,
Black Adam and the JSA.
And just so you guys know, and
many of you probably do know,
the JSA pre-dated
the Justice League.
So, the JSA was the very first
superhero group, man,
and we stand them on their feet
in "Black Adam,"
and it is amazing.
-It pays off.
It's so good.
And then, we all stayed
to watch the credits.
And you go, "Is there going to
be a post-credits scene?"
And, of course,
no spoilers here.
Let's just say,
something happens,
and people are gonna freak out.
[ Laughter ]
-That's --
-People are gonna freak out.
And fans have been kind of
asking this for a long time.
And I heard that you had
a lot of responsibility
for making what happens happen.
-So, when you guys see the
movie, you see "Black Adam,"
what you're gonna see --
Like I said,
we want to build out
the DC Universe,
introduce Black Adam,
introduce other characters,
as well, in the JSA.
I have been saying
this is a new era in
the DC Universe that I love,
that we love.
It's a new era.
Yes, we're going to introduce
new characters.
But, also, the new era means
listen to the fans.
You've got to listen
to the fans.
And for a very long time,
for years,
you guys know,
fans have been screaming.
They've been upset, like, "Hey!"
We established Black Adam
as the most powerful
and unstoppable force
on this planet.
The most powerful
and unstoppable force
in the entire universe has been
on the sidelines for too long.
So, myself, Seven Bucks,
Danny Garcia, Hiram Garcia,
we fought, and we weren't gonna
take no for an answer.
We were gonna deliver it
to the fans.
And then, at the end,
um...welcome home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It pays off.
[ Laughter ]
I knew you were here,
and we talked about this.
You know I'm a fan of Teremana.
Congrats on all the awards
you win for this.
-Yeah, thank you man.
-I thought we would do
a celebratory shot
for "Black Adam."
This is the Añejo.
-This is the Añejo.
Thank you very much,
and thank you guys, by the way.
You have made --
There we go.
♪♪
You have made Teremana tequila
break all records
in the spirits business.
We're gonna toast "Black Adam."
But I want to say, dude,
I want toast you
for years of just being
really so kind.
And you've really
been the best to me,
and I really appreciate it,
even at a time in my career
when not everybody was.
So, thank you, man.
-Oh, I love you, man.
-Cheers.
Love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I appreciate that.
♪♪
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dwayne Johnson
in "Black Adam."
Take a look at this.
-I told you
to stop killing people!
-They look alive to me.
-Because I saved them.
-Well, that's why I waited
until you were there.
I got the information I needed.
No one died.
I did it your way.
-He does have a point.
-I know it got lost
in all the confusion,
but we still have
some issues to settle here.
There are only heroes
and there are villains.
-You think yourself a hero,
but you would let
these criminals go free.
-Heroes don't kill people.
♪♪
-Well, I do.
-That's exactly right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I do."
-"I do."
Black Adam does.
-Thank you, again,
for being here.
-Oh, absolutely, man.
-The New York City premiere
of "Black Adam" is tonight,
and so you have to run.
Tonight, biggest premiere
of my life,
biggest movie
of my entire career.
We are celebrating here.
We've come back home
to New York City.
The big global premiere
of "Black Adam," black carpet,
we have locked down
Times Square tonight.
Every theater
is "Black Adam'd" out.
And I want to raise this glass.
I raised it to you.
We raised it to "Black Adam."
Now I want to raise this
to all of you
because all of you are coming
tonight to the premiere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's what I'm talking about!
Thanks to our friends --
Thanks to our friends at IMAX!
-Thank you
to our friends at IMAX!
-You're gonna see it at the
biggest theater tonight!
-Tonight!
-With Dwayne Johnson!
"Black Adam" is in theaters
and IMAX October 21st.
Dwayne and I are doing
something fun after the break.
Stick around.
That's how you do it, bud!